yeah speaking of Aussie things though I
did find a list I don't know if this is
accurate but I feel like since we have a
live crowd uh we can test how accurate
it is okay uh because it's a list of
things most Aussie do uh most Aussies do
that you guys now consider normal
so okay I want to test this out sure
okay okay so number one
steal a trafficker and on the side of
the road to take home
why why are you proud of this because
everybody has done this first of all
they're called witch's hats
we don't call them traffic cones
is it this widespread I thought it was
because in England we still do it but
only like uni age you know that's that's
a uni thing to do I don't know wasn't it
like Trafalgar Square where they kept
putting it on top of it like this this
like 20 meter tall statue yeah they just
kept getting a cone on top of it no one
knew how and whenever they removed it
some dude just put it back that's
amazing no one knows how I love that all
right number two I I saw this and I was
like I've never heard of anyone do this
before so this might just be the list
okay hang a sack of wine to a
clothesline
so I found out that different states
call it different things so what do you
guys call it in Melbourne
the what no no no no not not goon like
the actual game of putting it on the
clothesline and spinning it around you
know the game I'm talking about wait
hold a fortune right up I've missed like
five steps okay okay let me explain let
me see let me explain so
here's another Australia is known for
inventing a lot of things like that have
helped a lot this is something that
should not be invented we invented Wi-Fi
great invention we invented the
lawnmower great invention we also
invented the Goon
which is just our way of calling uh wine
which is really [__] wine you put it
into a bag and then you stuff that into
a box it's basically box wine but we
call it goon and there is a uh and also
because Australia is such a heavy
drinking culture we come up with a lot
of
really dumb drinking games and one of
them uh is called goona Fortune
um which is basically uh you know those
like cloth uh hang uh what is it the the
the clothing lines right that you can
spin
have you have you do you know these wait
what no okay I found out only Australia
has this so basically in your backyard
there is this like a clothesline but
it's this like think of like a giant uh
like parasol essentially it's the shape
of a parasol but if there's like
clotheslines on it and you can spin it
I don't know why why would you want to
spin it to play goon a fortune obviously
cool so basically go to Fortune is this
game where you you if your mate uh has a
spinning clothesline in the backyard and
someone has a goon sack which everyone
does
um you you pin up the goonsack onto this
uh thing everybody stands around the
clothesline and then just like Wheel of
Fortune which is what it's named after
you spin the clothesline and wherever
the goonsack stops you got to take a sip
so how does this involve wine when do we
get wine how are you supposed to hang a
beer
why do you want to hang a beer well
that's what I'm saying you got to hang
it to the clothesline right and a goon
bag is just in a bag so it's really easy
to hang up also it tastes like [__] so
no one wants to do it right which is the
whole point of a drinking game this
sounds so bad I know I I feel like this
is your way of sticking it to the French
I'm convinced that's it
everyone has their own way right
everyone has their own okay Alice is
good a fortune number three of course I
heard us with this one before drink
alcohol out of a shoe yep
good old Chewie who here has actually
done a Shoei
that is that guy does a chewy every
morning
I can't start my morning without a Shoei
uh yeah Chewie's uh horrible don't don't
yeah I'm actually glad because the ratio
of you guys that have done a Shoei
wasn't as high as I thought it was I
know so that's because no that's because
we're in a city
oh and there's things to do in a city
when you're in rural Australia there's
nothing to do other than to a Shoei
all right uh number four is mix
chocolate and Vegemite
I don't know
who's done this before
yeah yeah
[__] that's that's horrendous I mean
like okay Vegemite is already this one
thing that divides Australians like it's
like not toy in Japan right like not
every Japanese person likes not doing
the same way not every Australian likes
Vegemite who here likes Vegemite
I like Vegemite it's really good okay
maybe I was wrong
the most common at least my midnight
snack when I was in uni was Vegemite and
cheese sandwiches
yeah that's the [__] you take some you
take a slice of light nice bigger cheese
and you put some Vegemite on it two
pieces of bread you bite on that [__] oh
instant nut it's so good I like how you
tell me what a Vegemite and cheese
sandwich was like how like like I
wouldn't have known how to build yeah
those two ingredients just in case you
did two pieces of bread just in case you
didn't know thank you for clarifying I
have I don't know what kind of psychotic
person would mix chocolate with Vegemite
though that sounds
that's uh he's a word you can learn in
Australia that sounds rank
what else what else yeah all right uh
you're gonna have to explain this one I
don't know if this is part of Australian
history yeah but have a national debate
about sausage sandwiches
[Applause]
wait wait
what to what level are we talking
National debate I have no idea this is
just what the list says are you guys
that passionate about sausage sandwiches
or is there a point you know I mean
everyone knows how good the Bunnings
sandwich is all right
uh
so bunny so we have this hardware store
called Bunnings Warehouse uh lowest
prices uh every day
um and every Sunday morning they uh they
basically just pull a barbecue out and
they give out sausage sandwiches to
people
um I used to get Sunday lunches there
all the time that sounds good yeah it's
great
um I don't know about like the debate
thing because like how I don't know
maybe it's like do you like onion on it
or I think maybe this
[Applause]
all onions all right
is that the debate
[Applause]
oh oh okay thank you yeah the debate is
do you use two slices of bread to
sandwich the sausage or do you use one
slice of bread
yeah
that I think I think that's the debate
explain it again explain it again okay
so in Australia how we do it is we don't
waste bread right we want to eat the
[__] sausage so we take one slice of
bread kind of put it like diagonally put
the sausage diagonally in the middle and
then fold it up like a like a year what
and that's a sausage sandwich right most
other countries though use two slices of
bread and to kind of sandwich it
together yeah right yeah but not in
Australia
you know what I'm on the Aussie side of
things I use one slice I use one slice
because we have to do this every time I
have a barbecue in England yeah I am
back every everyone makes a sausage
sandwich in England which we sometimes
think when we have a barbecue yeah and
everyone uses two slices of bread if we
don't have hot dog breads but I'm that
guy who just uses the one slice I don't
know it's just optimized two breads it's
me okay two slices of bread is too much
yeah it's easy it's easy to hold listen
you're just lazy all right
I get it it's a lot of work I I also you
know I get fancy I cut the sausages in
half so they stay still and it's dude
it's so much better
okay okay let me okay okay hold on
though I have a fact about Australia
okay
what now you're gonna
I I again this might have been I made it
the [__] up I I heard
[__] stupid I heard that one of your
Prime Ministers [__] himself in a
McDonald's
yeah
now that's the man I can vote for
[Applause]
I'm kidding I'm kidding I'm kidding yeah
[__] himself in a McDonald's
which one oh scomo yeah yeah Scoma Scott
Morrison we call him Scoma he [__]
himself in a McDonald's he [__] himself
into McDonald's
I mean average day at a McDonald's if
you ask me so so uh are we proud of this
that uh
I mean what other country can say like
how prime minister [__] himself there
was also like one of your Prime
Ministers was had the quickest uh pint
drinking time or something oh yeah yeah
yeah yeah yeah like how the
deciding your prime minister
buy that clearly
it's like whoever won the box wine gets
to run the country yeah well I mean John
Howard won because he had the thickest
eyebrows right what yeah we had it we
had a prime minister called John Howard
and he had these like [__]
caterpillars it's okay I mean it's
insanely thick well we picked our prime
minister based on how stupid they are so
don't worry
about it join the club is uh part of the
election process having to do a Shoei at
this point like what what's that I mean
if you ask me they should bring that in
to be honest like I feel if you're a
true Australian you can do a Shoei and
come out on top and be like yeah that
was nothing give me another one funeral
fortune next this is a terrible way of
getting a private that's a terrible idea
uh all right next one this was pretty
random like uh make coffee in avocado
I have never heard about that all right
all right that's some like rural
Australia [__] like okay I mean
especially here in Melbourne that has
like I would say yeah especially they
wouldn't do that in Melbourne especially
when I would say you guys have the best
coffee in the [__] world
honestly Conor you're the coffee guy out
of the three of us it's good what do you
think it's pretty good pretty good it's
pretty good it's kind of crazy how much
good coffee there is just everywhere
yeah it's so unfair [__] you guys man
[__] you he don't miss all right okay
that that whole coffee and avocado thing
I don't know